and new warning signs that a recession
could be on the way
all three major stock indexes took a
serious beating to start the week and
we've got our vlad duterte here
following the story vlad i used to work
on wall street you know this area what
are we looking at here we're looking at
tony a bear market which generally means
an index like the dao has fallen 20
percent or more from its high the s p
fell into bear territory yesterday
closing at more than 20 percent below
its january high the dow is down more
than seven percent from just a week ago
dropping 876 points just yesterday now
all eyes are now on the federal reserve
and it's chairman jerome powell who's in
a tough spot here's why if the fed
raises interest rates later this week
experts say it could send the market
into deeper bear territory if the fed
does not raise rates inflation could
keep rising and right now gas is at more
than five dollars a gallon food prices
are up 10 in the last year and the cost
of travel is up 38
and all those things could go even
higher vlad thank you so much so with
the cost of living going up and our net
worth going down let's bring in cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger with
some perspective and hopefully some help
for those watching so how significant is
a bear market and what does it mean for
the everyday american well look i mean
it's significant they don't happen that
often but about a dozen times since
world war ii it depends on how long bear
markets last and to really determine
that we got to wait for the future and
that's so hard to do so if you look at
our most recent bear market in 2020 it
was really short we had a five-week
period where the s p 500 lost a third of
its value then it came roaring back
sometimes a bear market can be a
self-fulfilling prophecy for a recession
it's not inevitable but it can mean that
there's a leading indicator it means
that corporations aren't making as much
money investors are kind of wigged out
and consumers are really freaked out
also we had a university of michigan
confidence index released friday it was
at a 50-year low so consumers feel less
confident today than they did amid the
worst part of covent i think this is
significant didn't jamie dimon just say
the other day get ready for an economic
hurricane is this what he was talking
about yeah i think that this is not
exactly what he was talking about
because a lot of ceos whether it's
whether it's jamie dimon or james gorman
or david solomon the three big
investment banks what they're talking
about is the economy more than the stock
market the stock market can recover
pretty quickly the economy we're not so
sure about right now we're at a
crossroads as vlad said we have a
federal reserve meeting it's starting
today and the federal reserve has to
thread this needle they want to slow
down the pace of inflation but by
raising interest rates right what's
happening is they could actually tip us
into a recession if they go too far too
fast and the the real hurricane could be
if we're in a recession
still having high prices that's called
stag a stagnating economy with high
prices stagflation is someone out there
with a job offer on the table now does
that mean you should take it rather than
wait out well listen the one part of the
economy that has been strong is
consumers continue to spend you know if
you look at the airport travel data we
are seeing people on airplanes despite
those 38 increases in airfares so people
are spending jobs are actually plentiful
right now so yes i think it is a good
time to take that job or solidify it but
be clear when we have recessions it is
important to go back to your financial
basics that emergency reserve fund
paying down your debt and if you are
still working don't stop putting money
in the market this is your time to force
yourself to buy at lower levels right
the aggressive good advice thank you
jill thank you